l'éventail de sanctions qui a frappé la
Russie est sans précédent il vise en
premier lieu des individus proches du
régime des entreprises aussi comme JSC
scientific reserch institut submaron qui
conçoit des composants liés à
l'aéronautique et aux spatial mais aussi
Baïkal Electronics un fabricant de
semi-conducteurs cela dans le but avoué
d'empêcher le pays de se doter de
technologie de pointe alors concrètement
que représente ces mesures punitives au
total l'Union européenne a délivré 11
paquets de sanctions visant diverses
entités le département du Trésor
américain annonçait récemment que plus
de 2500 sanctions contre des individus
des entreprises et des institutions
avaient été mises en application la
Commission européenne revendique de son
côté une perte sèche de 43,9 milliards
d'euros d'exportation vers la Russie et
91,2 milliards d'euros d'importation
vers l'Europe
en d'autres termes le régime de Vladimir
Poutine hyperdrait deux fois plus que
les Européens le gouvernement américain
affirme quant à lui que ce sont près de
280 milliards d'euros d'actifs bancaires
qui auraient été gelés par Washington et
ses alliés ce qui représenterait 70% des
actifs du système bancaire russe il faut
ajouter à cela la confiscation d'environ
20 milliards d'euros d'actifs détenus
par des individus et des entités russes
et pourtant l'économie russe semble
résister contre vents et marées la
récession prévue par les économistes n'a
atteint que 2,1% en fin d'année 2022
contre les 6% attendus la réussite
continue même de gagner de l'argent en
2022 elle annonçait un excellent
commercial de plus de 284 milliards
d'euros c'est une augmentation de plus
de
77%, les enseignes de luxe sont partis
mais ça ça concerne pas la majorité des
Russes et ceux qui veulent se produire
des produits de luxe et bien c'est les
produits par des voies détournés et
c'est d'ailleurs une bonne partie de
cette des explications de cette
résilience russe je parlerai
c'est-à-dire des importations parallèles
qui passent par des pays comme le
Kazakhstan il y a clairement eu des
nouveaux circuits commerciaux qui se
sont établis ce qu'on peut voir par les
données notamment de l'Organisation
mondiale du commerce c'est que des flux
ont gonflé un exemple par exemple
l'Arménie tout petit pays voisins de la
Russie
les échanges commerciaux entre la Russie
et l'Arménie ont explosé en 2022 2023
idem pour le Kazakhstan son économie qui
normalement devrait se trouver dans une
situation délicate semble mieux se
porter qu'avant l'invasion trois
facteurs peuvent expliquer cette
résilience le premier c'est le pivot
vers l'Asie entamé avant l'invasion de
l'Ukraine la Chine a ainsi remplacé
l'Europe elle est devenue le principal
débouché des exportations russes
celles-ci sont passées de 27,6% sur la
période 2019-2021 à 52% en décembre 2022
autre parfois numéro 1 le débouché
européen a donc été remplacé non
seulement par la Chine mais aussi par la
Turquie et la progressivement les
exportations de gaz russes vers l'Europe
ont diminué ils sont à peu près 5 fois
moins de qu'il ne l'était avant la
guerre mais c'est largement du fait de
la baisse de la demande des clients
européens ça n'a rien à voir avec des
sanctions stricto sensuelles en revanche
le pétrole russe l'Inde a multiplié
pratiquement par 10 ces achats de
pétrole russe depuis le début de la
guerre c'est devenu un des principaux
clients du pétrole russe des lits
notamment il trouve son compte en
raffinant le Brutus puis en le
réexportant à l'Union européenne avec
une marge considérable au plan financier
la Russie se repose de moins en moins
sur le dollar et diversifie ses réserves
de change l'or le uan le dire à
menmirati ou même le rouble lui
permettent d'être moins dépendantes des
monnaies occidentales deuxième
explication la dette du pays la Russie
est en effet considérée comme un pays
rentier qu'est-ce que cela signifie et
bien cela veut dire que la majorité de
ses revenus sont tirés de l'exportation
d'hydrocarbures cette manne financière a
permis au pays d'éviter d'emprunter
ainsi la dette publique russe est
estimée à 20,9% seulement du PIB quand
celle de la France s'élève à 98% cette
marge de manoeuvre considérable permet
au régime de s'afficher comme un état
prenant ses finances au sérieux cela lui
permet donc d'emprunter facilement alors
que les sanctions ont justement pour but
de tarir ses sources de financement
enfin la dernière raison le prix du
baril de pétrole la Russie et l'Arabie
Saoudite membre de l'OPE plus ont
annoncé le 5 septembre vouloir continuer
de réduire leur production de pétrole
jusqu'à fin 2023 une annonce qui a
propulsé les prix du baril à leur plus
haut niveau depuis 10 mois il s'affiche
aujourd'hui après de 90 dollars cette
politique permet à la Russie et à son
économie entière de se reposer sur
l'exportation de pétrole pour se
financer et combler son déficit public
malgré le plafonnement des prix mis en
place par les Occidentaux alors la
question se pose jusqu'à quand cette
situation peut-elle durer il y a quand
même
une mentalité et une histoire qui font
que ce peuple
a l'habitude
de
rester ce que disent les experts c'est
que si les sanctions mortes ce sera de
toute façon à moyen voir à long terme ça
va petit à petit privé la Russie de
capacité de maintenir une croissance de
changer son modèle économique qui repose
vraiment sur les hydrocarbures et ça
c'est un moyen voire long terme quand
son apercevra